ومن موسكو ينضم الينا مراسل الفرنسيات
مازن عباس مازن مرحبا واهلا بك مازن همم
كما كل يوم هناك تطورات عديده همم في
اوكرانيا على الساحه الميدانيه وايضا
تطورات همم اخرى سياسيه ودبلوماسيه
ميدانيا هناك تضارب همم مثلا اليوم حول
خبر السيطره على احدى المدن همم في
اوكرانيا في الشرق الاكرانيا بين الجيش
الروسي الذي يقول بانه سيطر عليها وبين
الاوكرانيين الذين ياكلون بان القتال
المتواصل فيها
[تصفيق]
الدفاع الروسيه تركد انها سيطره بشكل كامل
على كافه احياء مدينه سويدان
تنفذ عمليات قصف بالمناطق الشماليه لمهبط
وايضا على محور دانيتس بهدف قطع الامدادات
عن القوات الاوكرانيه بالتالي كده انها
عمليا تسيطر على الوضع بشكل كامل والله في
طريقه له التحرك
بهدف استاذ السيطره على كافه اراضي اقليم
دانيتسك واخراج القوات الالكترونيه منها
طيب مازن في الشق
الدبلوماسي تحديدا او يعني هو مربوط ايضا
بشكل عسكري اهميه زياره وزير الدفاع اليوم
الى مناطق عمل هالكوات الخاصه الروسيه همم
كيف تاتي او كيف نفهمها ونقراها وخصوصا في
ظل ما يقرا او ما ينشر عن احباط كبير يصيب
عدد كبير من افراد الجيش الروسي بسبب
الخسائر البشريه بسبب طول امد الحرب وبسبب
الصعوبات التي تواجهم ايضا على الارض في
همم مع القوات الاوكراني اياها
يعني لا شك ان التعامل مع زياده
اليوم الى منطقه الى قطاع الصبح انما هي
تاتي خطوه في اطار اعلنهم عن التغييرات
الكبيره التي فتحدث على مدار العوامل
الثلاثه القادمه باعتبار ان ان الكريم لين
اتخذ بالفعل قرار بل ونفس نتيجه اجراءات
تستهدف زياده عدد التعداد القوات الروسيه
العامله بعد ان كانت مليون اصبحت مليون
و150,000 جندي
وايضا تطوير اسلحه هذه القوات اا بهدف اا
فرض النفوذ العسكري على همم مناطق
الاقليميه الاربعه التي انضمت للسياده
الروسيه هذا من جانب ومن جانب اخر ايضا
تنظر
بتصعيد عسكري خلال الاسابيع القادمه همم
باعتبار ان هناك همم التعديل في
استراتيجيه الهجوم الروسي التي تنفذ يعني
كانت على مدار شغل الثلاثه الماضيه روسيا
اختفت بعمليات القصر المدفعي والصاروخي
وايضا الجودي اما اليوم فبدا تتحرك
ميدانيا على المستوى البري همم حيث همم
دخلت قوتها منطقه ايزيسحه السوليدار وايضا
المناطق المحيطه بها اذا هناك تغيير ينذر
بخطه هجوم واسعه ليه فرد سيطره القوات
الروسيه على مناطق على الاراضي الاقاليم
الاربعه وبالتالي تاتي خطوه شيبوب وفي
اطار همم تنفيذ او اتخاذ القرارات
الملائمه لتنفيذ هذه الخطه هذا ما يتحدث
عنه المراقبون الروس اليوم في مصر
شكرا لك مراسلنا منكم مازن عباس